we weren't seeing my friends in the
lobby I saw a bill and Peter and Michael
sitting on the lobby I feel bad seeing
my friend just sit in the lobby waiting
he should be brought back immediately
no but if I wasn't out there I wouldn't
have got to see Jim scamper up the
stairs just showing off his incredible
cardio yes scamper executive yeah yeah
it's a little cleaner and there's less
people that use this yeah you don't want
the guest [ __ ] are downstairs there so
that's well that's wonderful Jim doesn't
waste any time on stairs when [ __ ]
is involved yeah it's gonna be all
toilet time I was afraid you know some
of the interview I'm like these guys are
gonna start like a lot of times I come
back in the show has already started so
I wanted to make sure they're here for
the entire Jim you have that comedic
internal clock and you just realize you
had a little window to [ __ ] and you and
your little inseam went up the stairs
alright 20 seconds to spare yeah it's
incredible there's a live reading from
the bill you did why it's not
comfortable all right so who are we here
with Jim well we're here with you and
Peter Billingsley as well as Michael
price there it is I'm gonna guess it has
something to do with November 30th f is
for family season three steered it drove
it right to the United unite me and I
were in the right direction I knew what
you wanted so how did you guys get
together as the trifecta responsible for
this show this filthy cartoon is awful
filthy adult cartoon let's protect the
children you know let's make sure
parents know not to let the children
watch it because it could be damaged
damaging to other animated children that
watch I was walking down the street one
day and I said I want to do a cartoon
show with swinging testicles yeah that's
how it started right engine looked for
other people that shared that vision yes
right that makes sense no I was just
basically telling childhood stories on
stage and in the beginning of my career
when I was just a young lad
those jokes would kill and then
somewhere along the line all of that
stuff kind of got labeled is like oh
that's mental abuse that's bullying
that's this that's that so they start I
started getting like ahh and was
frustrating so I stopped telling him and
then I don't know one day I was thinking
what if I just made like animated shorts
you know and of course I'm a comedian so
I never did
and I think I opened for Steve Byrne and
I met ya
Vince Vaughn of a Wild West company we
then came in and I pitched the show to
Peter and I literally was just like I
don't have any ideas for shows none of
my pilots ever get picked up if you guys
are doing anything and you want to throw
me in it I would love to do that and he
was like all right all right and then I
was I was walking I was I mean I do have
this idea for a cartoon and he was like
what we're looking to do something
animated and yeah and then it just kind
of these guys are like yeah they're like
the best in the business as far as like
what would you call production company I
don't know I don't know their terms up
yeah well yeah they just put next thing
you know I'm talking to Mike Mike came
in the great Mike price from The
Simpsons yeah
and I got to say that OC beats me in the
way no [ __ ] time for you do you think
Steve Byrne is happy he introduced you
to Vince Vaughn I ever taken anyway
visit any of his me time away you know
I'm busy as hell so you know so I still
when I'm talking to Vince I see him
looking over my shoulder he knows he see
Steve he's my best article so when you
in Vince you're talking well he like
Vince kind of make an effort to make eye
contact with Steve as well yes yeah
you're included and I see you part of me
dies inside a little bit yes now he's
teased the best and he actually is on
this season we wrote this this character
Chet and like dude he I think yeah he
just he's so great
yes he there really ought to be
something some sort of hardware for that
man in the end like something you know I
don't I've never been on the thing that
gets the award or whatever but this
might be something at least gets us
maybe I'll at least have to rent a
tuxedo he gave us so many great takes of
scenes that we had like spent hours and
hours in the editing room like finding
just the best 20 seconds of like like an
hour and a half of just pure I know and
you didn't want to cut anything Victor
he really is one of the funniest guys
definitely of his generation and of all
time and uh yeah so I got to be in the
booth with him just hanging on for dear
life I'm like I'll just do you do what
people are do you do it seven easily
animation as a lot of times are done
separately or will you actually do it
with people in the room some people are
cool with just
by themselves Vince always wanted you
know somebody there which is really cool
because then you can kind of do like the
overlap and Sam Rockwell's like that
you know we actually have a couple of
Oscar winners on our show now probably
always your intention right I wanted to
this cartoon show but my childhood we
get some Oscar winners right yeah yeah
Allison Janney it wore a dirt because it
kind of grounded it you know like the
this show is funny but it's also hits a
lot of dramatic themes uh-huh and so we
were kind of like how do you separate
yourself as a cartoon and by we were
fortunate to get Sam and Laura to join
up and so we're like okay maybe this
sort of sends a better message right is
there do you guys ad-lib and then
animate around that when you have
somebody like a Vince Vaughn or someone
who's just going yeah you go like okay
we're gonna record a dialogue first
it's kind of like you do one or two like
how we wrote it mm-hmm and then Vince is
just like well here's the stratosphere
of what you were trying to do yeah one
episode I think it's the third episode
this year that ends with Vince's
character talking to Bill's character
and it was so much funny stuff that we
just like said let's just keep it going
so like credit you know on Netflix like
unfortunately sometimes with Netflix
like the show ends and then like the
next one starts in like two seconds
unless you quickly hit this button
saying stay on right yeah on episode
three stay on the credits because then
Vince goes off for like another four
years all about this insane room he's
gonna build in Frank Murphy's house
times if you let it play that you
actually will miss that because so we
try to make the show goal have funny
stuff all the way through the end
sometime so there's a couple episodes
like that but that one especially we did
an airing machine right we did the beat
on the answering machine he called back
[Laughter]
so do you find that the the stories that
were once like these stories of mental
abuse and the things that people felt
sympathy for if you animate them does it
soften it in the sense that people are
like oh well this is just a cartoon or
you know we actually we will do the
over-the-top version and then every once
in a while we like
let's just sit in the sadness of this
which you know so it's not because if it
wasn't I you know it was afraid that was
just gonna be one note just you know me
yelling the whole time so we definitely
have like you know like all those
stories we should tell like the table
like everyone I was like I don't know
like six years old or something and for
my birthday my mother and father had
bought me this whole cowboy outfit I
swear to God like back when that was
considered you know I would be this like
these people were murderers so she puts
the whole thing on had the Hat a little
bandana a little holster and all that
and just like sent me outside and I
don't even think I made it to the end of
my driveway big kids just descended on
me they took the guns out of my holster
and just they they supposed to have like
mother-of-pearl but they were black and
white plastic they just smashed him on
the head and walked into the house and I
just handed my broken guns to my mom she
goes well who did this that was just
like big kids right and she I don't know
she died just sat down and she made me a
sandwich and that was so to the end of
it right it was like my birthday I was
like really sad I was the day after my
birthday and like so like those are
those things where like the animation of
big kids descending and like what that
feels like as a little kid right that's
why you can kind of take but that sad
walk up the driveway by yourself with
your broken toy like that's also
something that we like to have and when
you look back and you realize they were
right the big to do that some kid cowboy
outfit there's some guy in a headdress
in a van come on that's the other thing
you get back in the house and you think
well okay somehow my guns are gonna get
fixed or my mom's gonna make it okay or
whatever it is and when you just get
that sandwich you realized that this is
what happens now those guns are gone
yeah they've smashed them and all you
can do is sit here and eat this sandwich
and live in it but you also like a
little bit like a dog when you're that
young were just like 10 minutes ago of a
sudden didn't happen I was just kind of
eat the sandwich got the restless leg
going you know let's go play with
Lincoln Log did you take the Hat
now fit offer did you leave the rest of
it on for a little oil I think I
probably sadly removed my hat at the
table no but all of these types of
things like that's the [ __ ] when we get
in the editing room like what if he took
his hat off you know once you see it
because it's not like you just read it
and you're like oh it's gonna look like
this it's like you you record it and
then we send it to these the people that
animate it and then it's it's like their
take on top of that you know and you
know they always you know make really
great choices and sometimes they'll just
steer it a direction that makes us go
like oh [ __ ] you know be funny what if
we added this and we're always like
we're along we got to cut something out
and that's one of the reasons why I
don't like the editing process other
than the fact that it's really tedious
is there's all these [ __ ] jokes that
I love yeah yeah and you know mike has
to be the bad guy gonna say we got to
move on this there's no time we're
already we're over 30 seconds see nest
in here yeah I guess you know we get an
oval no one's gonna remember all right I
guess you forget especially with the
Simpsons and stuff like that like
animated shows that even if they're full
of jokes and you just recite the lines
if you're just watching them you don't
realize there's actually an episodic
structure here in timing in like you
have your move and tell a story and go
someplace that's where these two guys
coming cuz I am just like I'm just the
joke machine doesn't move the story it
doesn't yeah I did each episode would
just be like it would just go for about
40 minutes and slowly Peter out just
break the fourth wall wave run walk away
and then funny jokes remember stuff with
the animation we like go back and like
nah that's not how we saw it and they'll
actually redo something oh sure all the
time all the time because that yeah the
process is like we work on it tons we go
through like every show goes like
burette billets like five or six
versions of storyboards know what's
called animatic which is like the
animated storyboards and then
and we're constantly rewriting it
editing it adding these stuff moving
stuff around take the scene put it
before the other scene just anything to
make it work the worst is when there's a
line that you loved and it actually
killed in the booth and then it goes on
the screen and it just lays there and
you just you go why the [ __ ] doesn't
that work and I can never figure out the
answer but I just know it has to go like
oh we got to cut that line and just a
drive that drives me because I can't I
can't seem to figure out why some of
that just sometimes you do be in the
booth everybody like dying like oh my
god that's so funny and then it comes
comes back with nothing so it's like oh
my god and then never again as a fun
thing process if it's live action right
and you go shoot you got to get the set
the actors you got to schedule
everything then you hope that it all
works you get back you realize it
doesn't there's no shot at necessarily
going back on the set but an animation
it's just a pen and paper right like oh
it was what [ __ ] it well just range it
will just write that joke and boom we're
out sometimes in the final edit or
something we'll need like I'll be funny
if Bill at Frank had a funny noise here
or something will pull something that
bill did like two years ago
so our editor has like a file of like a
hundred versions of Franco have you
heard the the soundboard that they
created with your lines uh actually I
don't think I have I just know when I
just I can you know I've recorded him so
many times that when I was just watching
the Edit room and I'll do this I don't
know where the Frank will say something
I'll just look at Mike and we pulled
that from where the car their car spins
out of control and like exits frame and
you hear a crash into a fire hydrant and
we pull the thing from like two years
ago of you going you literally have
those conversations is that the right
and with this straight face is just like
you know that [ __ ] I just thought need
to be a little more shrill you know any
just sitting there you're talking like
you know the most filthiest words and
drying eloquently like you're talking
about wine well we have a couple options
here if we could sample like different
you know something we said we already
said [ __ ] like two pages before yeah
just I just want this [ __ ] to really hit
we always catch us we start laughing
going like what are we doing here I
think we have a [ __ ] barrel I took a
that's a something barrel as a comedy
writing term like oh the sock barrel
sometimes the [ __ ] barrel we what you
guys are doing tonight - and our tickets
available for it at the New York it's a
cotton New York Comedy Festival calm and
what are you guys doing it took a live
discussion yeah up like fans of the show
if they want to come down and you know
like we have like like the people that
are into our show or like crazy like
devoted rabid I mean they say [ __ ] in
the show that I don't even notice and
then they come up with all these
theories and all that stuff so it's sort
of our little mini comic-con they come
down they ask all these questions and uh
we've done a couple of these they want
to like Nashville it's fun because you
know we work so hard or not to see that
there's people out there that connect
with it and they're really yeah into the
show get people giving you like my
family and giving you a shift from their
family that they think you can animate
that's tragic like my father ran the
dogs over the lawnmower you know there's
definitely no iOS i like when when young
kids come up and actually still go my
dad's just like that and blah blah blah
blah blah which you know I don't want
anybody don't have a dad necessarily
there's a lot of good aspects of Frank
but like I also it makes me feel good as
a comedian going like I knew it like I
knew this stuff that I'm doing people
are relating to and just sorta all of
that [ __ ] that's out here now although
that progressive stuff where everybody's
sort of acting this thing but like you
know the stuff that they think is funny
or relate to is kind of still what it
was so it's really weird time so when
people do come up especially young kids
it you know it definitely you know I
think actually helps with my stand-up
act I just think of that well that
person thought it was funny so I'm gonna
try this in front of these young people
if someone comes up to you comes up to
you now it's like you know 2018 they're
seven like that my father does not
you're like [ __ ] - now like that was
okay thirty years ago alright they
consider abuse like soap in the mouth
yeah that was just what it was like
growing up and so I was like no that was
abuse
[Laughter]
compared to some of this stuff that
happens to other people around the world
I mean our idea of abuses is like you
know I don't think give me that list
this little abuse but like washing your
mouth out with soap I mean that was I
mean it really got the message it did I
remember my dad did it he was too much
of a softie as much as he screamed and
yelled he just sort of washed your face
you know but my mother would say use
like pump soap you know my mother was
just like stick your tongue out like
[ __ ] dragging it across and over and
we would all sit there laughing watching
it happened to one of my you know just
psyched it wasn't you but you know I
don't know I I when I look back on all
of those I don't have any anger about it
I just look back and be like yeah I was
I was an [ __ ] let's look at the
lessons that it's supposed to teach you
a minute ago you're sitting here yeah
just a bunch of adults sitting around a
table trying to figure out which [ __ ] to
really hit here
like it seems like it didn't stick 21
I'm allowed to drink round those words
no but we would just you know we had a
big family and stuff like that my mother
you know she had to like you know keep
control right like she dealt out the
beatings my dad was a bad time I figured
out my dad was a softy you know he was
just gonna be screaming and yelling
that's kind of all what it was but my
mother my dad was in a fraternity and as
a souvenir he kept the paddle you know
is this thing that you know stuff he
went through and then my mother used to
use it on us yeah I remember the last
time she tried she tried to beat me and
my older brother with the thing we were
just too big like it just this period of
time had gone by and we had hid the
thing and then she found it we were just
too big and we were like blocking her
blocking it Bragg arms they were just
laughing and all this [ __ ] and she was
trying like hell and we just kept
laughing that she finally quit and I
remember her eyes welled up and she just
looked at us and she just went it is
funny she walked out and it was worse
than any being ever me my brother both
went to bed like like [ __ ]
quiet like oh my god we just made our
mom cry I just wanted to rewind that so
you could just scream bloody murder and
make her feel good about herself yeah
destroyed mom's sense of being yeah
broker yeah it was just kind of like
yeah there was a number of those moments
so that's once again would be like
that's like one of those stories where
if you animated her like that whole
[ __ ] thing is funny and then out of
nowhere she starts crying it's just like
oh [ __ ] and I think you know most people
can relate to you know breaking your
parents are you having kids with a
wooden spoon last year and that was my
grandmother I kept messing up this throw
rug she was walking for some reason in
the kitchen then it was the living room
and then the dining room she had to walk
through the living room and I saw her
walk by there was this little throw rug
over this hole in the rug that the real
rug that we had and she just she bent
down to you who keeps messing up this
rug and I just immediately
oh here's the comedy so she went in and
I [ __ ] messed it up again and I did
it like four times and then she went
into the kitchen and then stopped and
quickly looked back out as I was messing
it up and dude she came at me with his
[ __ ] wooden spoon like a tomahawk and
I just remember I got my four I'm up and
it snapped over my four I'm and she had
this look around and after it's snapped
she just went back to being grandma and
she just went like well that's the end
of that spoon that just loans itself
better to animation because there is
that weird thing if you did that in
live-action I think people would just be
like what kind of messages is sending
and right love the tragedy yeah I want
you to keep getting beaten with a wooden
spoon to the point that the spoon breaks
like a laugh I feel bad about the actual
kid having to play the actor right like
I remember watching eastbound and down
and like feeling really sad for the kids
[Music]
like somewhere there was like a stage
mom saying listen to all this abuse yeah
I told that story before minute I was on
this sitcom and you know when you work
with babies you got to work with twins
because their own route to work for
three hours so you have one during
rehearsal and then the other one does
the actual shoot so this person showed
up with these twins and one of them was
absolutely catatonic like
you could have had a [ __ ] wolf
growling in its face and we just stared
the other one was screaming bloody
murder so we're like alright let's use
the docile one first and this kid will
calm down by then bla bla bla so we
worked the first kid for three hours
he's done right and then we go to do the
taping and they go to use the other one
the other kid is still crying
right so the dad quickly switches the
name basically Sam is now working a
double shift with this [ __ ] kid that
is like four hours into his workday and
all of a sudden of course right as my
lines coming this [ __ ] kid starts
losing it and the dead remember sugar
corn pops yeah big [ __ ] yellow things
he pushed it in the kids mouth as it was
crying I was making no noise it was
crying so bad he shoved this thing with
his thumb jammed in his mouth and then I
had to walk through this fake thing like
Schneider and the kid comes in screaming
and it fell out of his mouth I just felt
so filthy it's like I don't want to be a
part of this and then we actually
switched to a rubber kid we used a fake
baby and they should have told the crowd
they didn't I came walking up the thing
was like gray got this huge laugh like
people all felt like oh he's [ __ ]
with us and then they realized like no
they actually can try to pull this off
on the people at home and I was yeah I
literally had townies yeah way back in
the day way back in the day my first
like acting gig
it's amazing what stage parents will do
to get their kid on screen like he did
in that moment that guy wasn't a father
through when he switched the name he
looked at me and he winked and I was
just like yeah you stopped me into it
yes like to do you little three-card
Monte with your [ __ ] kids when I'm
not here you tried objective would have
put out corn pop in your mouth you could
choke on a corn pop and he shove you
into the baby's mouth fine the whole
thing was just like like that's not
gonna stop it like the kid's gonna
strike was screaming bloody murder like
that was gonna stop the kids oh yeah do
you get weirded out because of the
series how many people kind of know your
childhood stories now cuz you're pretty
private guy
because they're not they're not mud
they're just they're like amalgams of
all of our like all of like our stories
and stuff like that sorry right I wanted
my parents to be able to watch this and
not be like mortified that we put all of
that stuff out this is literally just
what yeah why would you like so if they
were to watch it if they could figure
out how to use Netflix and put in a
password because I don't think they've
even seen you if they sat down and
watched it they would be like elements
of little catchphrases or or if any of
my siblings were to watch it like this
this this things like in the pilot
episode when when Bill's up on the tree
and those kids are throwing rocks at him
like that really happened to me now they
didn't start shooting fireworks but me
my friend my friend we climbed up this
tree was just having a good time
climbing a tree because that's what you
did back then there was no iPads you
actually had to [ __ ] make your own
fun so we just climbed up this tree
these big kids just came along saw us up
there and just started throwing rocks at
us like a half hour hitting us at the
ankles we was up there Brian and they
had to make their own fun yeah and then
they just left and we just continued
cool after we got done sniffling and
crying we just continued and I remember
I went home I didn't even tell my
parents it was just it was just part of
the day like just you ran into big kids
you hid right just bad [ __ ] they just
would throw you down the hill or just
break your toys in the [ __ ] and it was
just sort of uh
yeah it was a lot more um free-for-all
you just kind of sent your kids outside
and they fended for themselves so what'd
you guys do you sit in the room and just
go all right and then just start
throwing out childhood stories and or
things that happened to and you were
kids and figured this works this doesn't
work yeah yeah especially if there's
like like a new character coming I feel
like I'm the only guy talking here but
like I just feel like like like if we do
like a new character like okay his uncle
comes to town then it's like I don't
even know you know we can't sort of have
like a story idea and then some would be
like man I mean wha
my friend down the street had an uncle
on this guy for some reason he always
wore this leather vest it just kind of
starts with that yeah like one of our
writers Emily put the thing in that was
in the first season where they did like
a slip and slide and they made it they
made like a homemade slip and slide out
of like plastic wrap and then we and
then the girls slid all the way through
and punched through it and like went
into the road like that actually
happened
Emily one of our writers so yeah that
kind of thing like that we just will
spend the first couple of days of a new
season just like throwing out those
stories and this year you know if we
started another season we might have
started again like that like what what
what's going on what's happened that and
we just sort of find a way to sort of
channel it into what we want to do and
then people just come up with like weird
little idiosyncrasies like I think Emily
also came up with the fact that the
bully for some reason like was really
into making birdie right he likes to
sing like he sings a lot of like musical
sort of songs while he's just he just
made him like a bully you know what I
mean it would just be give and get
boring after a while so yeah I have like
these things that he's like you know
this vulnerable stuff which was always
weird when you saw the bully like all of
a sudden show this side that boy why
bother ability like loud IQ should be
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of you right
now but none of us are big enough to do
it so now we have to sit in the
awkwardness that you're showing us this
thing is okay but our thing isn't yeah
what about you Peter when you were
growing up were you getting picked on
because you did a Christmas story
obviously when you were young you were
Ralphie like one of the most
recognizable things ever and when you're
that age being recognizable is not
always the greatest thing in the world
no it was different I started at
two-and-a-half acting so by the time I
did that in like 12 I had really good
parents which is fortunate and I wasn't
forced into it but I did this back in
the 70s like long before the child labor
laws or anything any kind of regulations
I remember I did a movie called honky
tonk freeway there's like this huge
movie I love John Schlesinger directed
it you should check it out it's really
cool to start this man like sort of the
back of the time it was like 79 and they
would always tell you when you're tired
and when you have to wrap like after the
three hours I'm like I'm not tired and
they said well we've got this other shot
you're gonna come back in the morning
and finish it I said I just want to
finish it now and be done I'm like no no
no you're tired so we let the
schoolteacher leave the social worker
wotcher I said bye I'll see in the
morning I went back to my trailer change
back in my shoot me out because I don't
want to come in in the morning they did
and then they just cancelled my work in
the morning so I was like 9 schedule
mapped out I knew what I wanted to do
the next day so it was easy she's never
worked outside of show business not know
I mean even the sort of odd jobs I had
when I went when I sort of moved behind
the camera I worked through
post-production that was really all that
I've ever done
wow man and a ton since 2 and a half but
again I had really good parents who
weren't pushing me like the corn pop guy
right so it was a very different journey
for it to be more fun like you wanted to
do it like I don't think Maine
nine-year-olds were that smart to the
business no I enjoyed yeah yeah and it
was really fun and Christmas story we
did in Canada uh-huh and I was a
resident of Arizona so there were no
child labor laws so I was doing 12-hour
days on that one and you liked it oh it
was great you wanted to do that yeah but
like truthfully if I was tired my mom
would say he's tired and we're done
right so it's like you don't sort of let
the clock tell you it's when you felt
like direktor getting mad the next day
how you doing this morning little Pete
do 100 shots at that Santa Claus witness
will you stop getting work like where
was like all right you were the cute kid
but now you're this age I transitioned
through the teen years and kept working
which are the tricky ones like puberty
when you get all awkward but then I just
didn't
I wanted new challenges so I wanted to
kind of move behind the camera and stop
acting and then I met Vince on an
after-school special which was one of
the last jobs I ever did as an actor and
one of the first jobs he ever did Oh
became good buddies and then his acting
career was taken off and then I sort of
went behind the scenes and so did you
have any sort of regularity to your
childhood or was it a lot of work all
the time it was a lot of work all the
time
I didn't play like a lot of work and I
support I played some but then I sort of
joined a team and then have to bounce
right um didn't I never graduated high
school I couldn't find a high school to
support me so I got my chip see my
California high school proficiency exam
what he means
for you in the sense that like his UB
guy it was gone so they didn't have any
idea how to send a curriculum and kind
of spur that's all changed now with
online but this was before the internet
so it was yeah very different school
specials were oh yeah there's like time
to go see it was a good gig you know
like it was a big deal you thought
there'd be a lot of eyeballs on it
that would still be a good time doing
after-school special intimate I mean I
won't watch one that was about drug
abuse they should call it the kid who
got a cowboy outfit was on drug abuse
and the one the older brother was like
this amazing swimmer and he was maybe
gonna get into the Olympics and the
other kid just didn't really have any
talent so he just started smoking weed
and doing all of this [ __ ] so they did
this whole [ __ ] thing where you know
he goes through the whole journey of it
so then he ends up getting cleaned up
the whole family intervenes he think
he's gonna be fine so the the the
Olympic swimmer he has to train one more
time out on this lake so he wants his
brother to row the boat to give him like
a pace to keep swimming too and I guess
he was on drugs or something like that
and he somehow hit him in the face with
the oar and he almost drowned so he felt
he felt so lesson he felt so guilty the
whole thing was don't do drugs see he
always keeps it on story like where are
we going bill the next day he goes into
the hospital he's goes he goes I feel so
bad and the older brothers being a good
[ __ ] about just be like now it wasn't
accident whatever he goes I was high
when I was rowing the boat and then the
guy just puts his hand over just like it
like the two black guys he goes get out
I'm telling this in details as so many
listeners might find it and this story
ended with him driving on a highway
wasted going through construction signs
and he just was singing
you just got screaming going something
yeah the construction sites Jimmy see
they were warning him that there was no
highway catchphrase in my family anytime
you were [ __ ] up you just think you
just
so you guys you guys didn't learn drugs
are bad from that ya know we should do
that if you were doing your homework and
your brother came in we go get out made
fun of it we thought if we thought it
was [ __ ] hilarious we didn't do drugs
because our parents told us not to do it
not because we watch this stupid [ __ ]
movie right I don't know maybe I guess
kids don't really watch regular TV when
they get home anymore cuz the only thing
that's on in those after-school hours is
like courtroom TV show reruns and just
to get home at 3:30 you'd run and watch
it you're right yeah that's a big deal
right yeah yeah nobody's want you to get
your lesson
you watch enough stuff on Netflix what's
the 13 reasons is that this on your
phone suicide show for teenagers yeah
yeah that's the new after-school
steroids and the all right
abuse of steroids in school and how bad
it was yeah by the way you know who is
in it for some I would assume I think we
found the name of year after school
special you know what is it they believe
it was called stoned Brian Jones story
[ __ ] there's always somebody that
remembers it I believe I'm a winner
stoned or if I put details in and
something comes up with well I don't
think it's the Brian Jones story because
that's from 2005 this is clearly that's
not it it's got nails from the Rolling
Stone don't it's still called stone but
apparently it's from 1980 and Scott
Baio's in it that was right they always
answer them neither I'm being told it's
and being informed in my ear yes it
apparently Scott oh god I got bail okay
Troy wrote Scott bail clay go to that
middle clip let's see if this is it Oh
Mike I haven't seen this since the
relearning cruise
come on in that for you parents working
I don't think this is it taking his time
all I wanted mark price could be I don't
know
Travis is saying on the the plot is
exactly what builder said on the
Wikipedia page just get to the last
scene he's going I'm a widow
we need the I'm a winner or get out get
out he forgives him and a swimmer how
about oars
yes all right whatever we don't need to
waste anymore that's amazing I'm gonna
watch that no matter what yeah I bet
it's the same one try that let's ride
right there he's in the hospital stone
part eight first one right think it was
shot on a hand he can all right say that
way I won't get out just get out on my
sound board disgust that guy was in a
million shows back in the day you all
right yeah I'm just fine he's got this
for me just get out
what happened
so they speak up what happened
clowning around ecommerce or is a
discover for dining around what a good
guy there's an amazing the pacing of
these old shows is like there'd be no
soundtrack and they would just allow the
silence yeah just sit he's just looking
around the room and you just allow it to
be dead in the room I'm excited to be
like lying the fact the father has one
question then gets angry are you okay
[Laughter]
that since 1980 by the end like a party
try part 9 part this is like it [ __ ]
wraps up yeah that's the end of it my
name is Jack not super Jack or stone
Jack look
oh wait a minute I combined two movies I
think you know [ __ ] you now it looks
like dirty Larry crazy marriage that was
a crazy married dirty Larry when they
died in the car at the end I think
you're joking not really marrying crazy
over that movie okay it looks like Jack
cleans himself up at the end of this
yeah he's smiling he's just he's just
yeah I guess she couldn't have somebody
died I combined two movies he's not
stoned Jack anymore
are you sure that doesn't die you sure
it's not the brother who was a good
brother I don't know maybe that this
ruined him why would that be an
after-school special yeah the good guy
kills himself that not maybe he doesn't
makes a mistake all right so now now if
you listeners can somehow find we have
to put we have to put after-school
specials yeah show you Brian Williams
that you conflated two things together
wasn't that's amazing that was that was
one of your last gigs though it was the
after-school special here under the
camera huh huh in terms of in front of
the camera yeah right yes [ __ ]
believe I just I have not seen that
scene in 38 years and then are you gonna
go home and try to find it again I've
never I've never well now I know the
name at least that I got no I'm sending
that to all everyone in my I'm a winner
construction site after school yeah yeah
in corporate I'm aware I'm a winner guy
end of movie yeah now I'm dying to know
this here it's amazing how impactful
these things are these things that you
watch they say kid you they memory with
you forever I mean I'm sure you know
from working on The Simpsons like yeah
every line on that show somebody knows
people have incredible hours and hours
of conversations just doing Simpsons
lines over and over there's these guys
on Twitter that just like every day they
include me in it for some reason but
it's like 40 40 quotes in a row just
like about what's going on their life
but with a Simpsons quote if you had any
ideas that's what was going on
feel like that would be a tremendous
responsibility like not only do we have
to write an episode but this is stuff
that people are just gonna say forever
around 650 or so right now as a gun
smoke was the longest gun smoke Wow yeah
we just passed Gunsmoke oh yeah I mean
you talk about the the progressive stuff
up who is under attack at all times G is
a family right now cuz I'm not that's a
thing that's being handled but let's
just say there may be convenience store
owner coming to F is for families when
you make a project any project it is you
don't know how culture is gonna change
in five years or ten years or all of a
sudden what you're doing now which is
perfectly acceptable is no longer gonna
be acceptable it's like how do you
there's no way to plan for that [ __ ] I
just realized how high in that chair
you're sitting Jim talked to me about
wanting to be in a position of authority
regardless of who the guest is he wants
to make sure that his chair raises just
slightly that's one reason why I think
with our show because we're set in the
1970s like we're just saying this is
we're just showing like this is what it
was like like that and you know kind of
score points about today necessarily
we're just sort of saying this is what
you don't know was try to navigate it
yeah because it's in the period right
right and just you can do what you want
this is how animated people talk to them
you can't get away with more in cartoons
I mean people just I just just agree
this is a fantasy world where nobody's
in any real danger right yeah yeah right
they're not real people I understand
their drawings is that
there was on The Simpsons where a comic
book guy was really mad because there
was a comic book where like Superman and
Batman both wanted to marry Lois Lane or
something and he tells Bart he goes he
goes that never happened you know and
then Bart says well technically none of
it ever happened there any is there
anything that you've done on The
Simpsons that you've been surprised as
resonated with people the way it has
well everything you know but and
everything yeah everything me personally
I don't know I mean I I can't think
about anything off the top of my mind I
mean the main thing is that like all
this weird stuff about how we predicted
Trump and all that stuff which didn't
really I mean we they wrote a show I
wasn't around they wrote a show 20 years
ago yeah set in the future where Lisa
was the president and the previous
president was Trump but but even then
but like 20 years ago in 1998 or 99 he
was already talking about how he was
gonna run in 2000 so it wasn't that big
of a leap they are convincing that when
you just throw up the screen grabs cuz
nobody actually goes back and checks the
episode right it just becomes a meme
that they just post the still weird mean
because then what happened was after he
announced and he did that thing where he
came down that escalator
yeah then we did a little short that
wasn't an episode of the series but a
little short we made for the Internet
where it was that like we were making
fun of that like he was coming on the
escalator and Homer was behind him like
looking into his hair or something and
so then people threw that up it's like
see we predicted it in 1999 but that was
a thing from like so that's that weird
stuff on you know the internet works but
yeah yeah there's no facts on is there
stuff you've wanted to do that they've
said no to like stuff the childhoods
true that did aren't you know the
opposite they would like go push it
further push it sort of the dream notes
that you you know when we were coming up
Oh Jimmy way back in the day when it was
all let's talking we build a sitcom
around your act they'd always you know
we want edgy we want edgy and then you
would go in there and then they would
just take your knees out and they would
just gut the whole thing the amount of
comics that I saw so funny on stage and
then you would watch the finished
product of what it turned into just
because of the pressure of advertised
and all that like Netflix doesn't have
any that so like yeah they they
literally there was one episode in the
early on season where the kid on
Halloween where he's wearing his pickle
cost
and the bully starts beating him up and
like he brought to it was two of his
friends original script it was like him
the bully and his two friends start
beating bill up and the people from
Netflix are like bring in more kids and
they're doing like wrestling moves and
they said yeah I make it more kids like
really just beat the [ __ ] out of them
yeah we were like alright that's alright
they're also like a kind of a young
company tool so that's like I just think
and the way they're doing everything was
just different
when we kind of got there but I remember
yeah when we got that that note to push
it further I was just I was just like I
thought it was a joke like these guys
I'm a [ __ ] serious like I this is
this is the the notes hype I've wanted
to get to the last 15 years where they
were usually the notes you get but but
who do we root for and aren't we
promoting this and then you just
eventually it's like alright he's a dumb
guy but is he's a lovable lug right his
wife is smarter and just you just you
just doing that which all of those were
just the bastardized version of the
crammed uns absolutely just he learns a
lesson during this yeah became like that
yeah but it was always just like you
know the Dumber the guy is like that was
[ __ ] hilarious but if you you had a
woman that was kind of dumb then that
was then it became all allow oh you know
that's not I don't know that's not Pro
women or whatever the favors it was so
[ __ ] frustrating so that's why when I
met sat down with Pete I was just I had
been through the wringer so many times
it's like I'm not gonna do another
[ __ ] deal cuz none of my [ __ ] ever
gets picked up and then I'm not allowed
to do anybody else's projects for like a
year and I was just like oh yeah so
that's that's why I said that Pete when
I came into office like yeah I know they
wanted to do them as five minutes and
instantly when I heard the idea I was
phenomenal and said let's do him is 30s
and then we got together and one thing
that we did was we wrote the script
ahead of time so a lot of time if you
pitch something they'll say oh great and
then you're in development right then
they you know you get the note so by
kind of creating the script ahead of
time having Bill attached you can sort
of say hey this is the show we're
delivering you wanted yeah like this is
the vision day now so I'm sitting with
Vince Vaughn right they're like Jesus
Christ decent to this and well I can
here's a script
so that's the lack of talent I have
that's how hard smart though you have
the script read this way they can't
start saying okay now we have pressure
to put our ideas in there you've done
the work for all this is the show yes
they're nervous that you're leaving with
this script is like what if somebody
else reads this and loves it right no
but I but I really think you know Peter
and and Mike sitting down and writing
the whole script and all that stuff and
then walking in with Vince's what put it
over the top at what point did you guys
realize like we have multiple seasons
here like they're gonna keep going with
this thing because I would imagine they
picked up the second because that's how
it's not like you're making them and
you're seeing how the ratings are going
you're continuing to write like the way
oh yeah ours is just like alright here
it is and then you wait three days and
then Netflix goes alright do it again
alright no it kind of underperformed and
yeah bye we're done they just here send
you out the porthole of their giant
[ __ ] spaceship The Simpsons ever
worried about being cancelled anymore at
this point no not really I mean it's
just gonna be a question of like when
you decide it's done right yeah I think
so you know Fox says they still want to
they want it you know and we want to
keep making it and as long as
everybody's happy and making the show
and everyone's still around did make it
it's like our only junior he decided
when the streak was over them yeah I'm
gonna sit down you could go somewhere
else if they cancel you could always
just go somewhere else you know somebody
would take it I think I don't think yeah
I mean you know there's all there's a
new world coming up between Fox and this
Disney thing and everything so that
might be make a little uncertain but
everything we hear is that Fox wants to
wants the show to continue and we'll
keep making you know what whenever they
do those things where it's like we're
showing every Simpsons episode ever you
know there's some lunatic out there with
like two VCRs yeah and still back you
know old-school tapes all of them yeah I
didn't think they did a thing when it
was either for the 20th anniversary or
the
500th episode or 20th anniversary where
they did a marathon where they showed
him all in a row and they set up this
tent on in this place in Hollywood where
they brought his people in like a dance
like an old-school Dance Marathon except
instead of dancing they were just
sitting on their asses and whoever could
make it through all the way like won
some big prize and I went over there
like after it was really ran for seven
days or eight days and I went there on
day six and these poor people were
sitting there like really really bad for
them do you watch it if it's on ever or
no sure I want you to yeah it's fun like
I was in London in in summertime and
just it's on all the time over there so
we just turn on TV and just happen to be
on so it was really cool it really is
amazing it's like I think FXX the app
they created an app that has every
episode every episode is on every
episode is streaming so there aren't
like all the people that's happened to
me and all my wrestling VHS tapes like
all the people that spent all their time
recording every single episode on their
tapes then this app comes out they're
like you know we have all the episodes
here in perfect quality and you're just
looking at all these VHS tapes like what
did I spend well you threw them out when
you were done right I still have
everyday kept his tape all of them for
what well they're all there and now like
in the writers room when I first started
like 15 years ago at the writers room
like if we wanted to remember something
like there were these books there were
these books they put out like you'd look
it up okay and then suddenly there was
Wikipedia and then there was like
Variety V DS and then now it's every
episode we could just pull of an episode
my stream like yeah watch it yeah
incredible but you feel like the the
tapes that you recorded off the TV or
this accomplishment so when something
comes out then it just makes them
completely obsolete you go okay but I I
got to keep my tapes I collected all
these don't sirens you need to upload
the commercials the right are the ones
those are the ones like we sit there
like that's like so much of the writers
room day is what what I just did there
was and there was this show and this guy
said lovely' and then we find it and we
laugh and you know sometimes it's just
as you're tired of thinking and other
times it's it actually ends up getting
into the end of the show like I think
that we've always talked about this just
this cold
cigar commercial we've had this joke
yeah three seasons in script that was a
story I told you like the first time we
ever met yeah on the show which is my
dad you know Frankie's a little bit
based on bills daddle with my dad my dad
never yelled at us like the you know
like Frank does but he would get mad and
he would yell at like inanimate things
like the TV so there used to be a
commercial for white owl cigars back in
the 70s with this guy sitting there and
going like you may not smoke white owl
cigars now but take one puff and you
will and he goes we're gonna get you was
like working construction here a bad day
that night he's like you're not gonna
get me white owl cigars commercial
commercial we're gonna get you we're
gonna get you he's been taking [ __ ] all
day like you the guy on TV
you're not gonna I think it's this one
here the second one yeah no the third
seventy one the third one okay go to
that third one all right let's see we're
gonna get you yeah white out what we're
gonna get weird
the guy's name was George S Irving oh I
have a weird bizarre trivia head for old
actors yeah it's like stump to schwa me
and he knows everyone that's the guy all
right let's see
[ __ ] like goddamn what oh here we go
okay aha no going why do they do why do
you remix it just put the thing you're
looking at worse that's it but they're
their remix to get worse I hate people
nobody you could see how smug he was so
well there it is that's not him either
original that's a different dude wow
that's a remake [ __ ] that guy
this one this one October 72 you got a
skit you got to skip forward a little
bit as I found it on here let's see you
find this is a smart episode what's on
their commercial montage wishing slow it
looked like a commercial running smart
and Joe Namath that was a [ __ ] Cooper
you know I think it's further it's more
closer to the beginning I love this but
you sat there watching Sue's reputation
for dependability Sears 19-inch color TV
sooner or later you're gonna try a
Whitehall and when you do we gotcha
[Music]
we're gonna get you know we're gonna get
you
[Music]
my dad was a blue-collar guy you know so
I think that guy represented like all
the rich know you I can get you to do
whatever I want no you can't even drank
is like Miller Beer we're gonna get you
hooked on smoking great like you never
know you just a guy in his chair he
doesn't even know his kids watching him
little does he know like that's the
memory like this is the memory that I'm
gonna leave my son with a little thing
else you know wine up on television
these weird things are gonna be one
someday someday we keep putting it in
the scripts and we keep cutting it
because it's like this doesn't work for
the moment so well we'll figure it out
so that kind of terrifies me about being
a dad that at some point your kids get
to an age that literally everything that
you say means something like it all
makes an impression on them and like
they know when they see you as a human
being yeah that's really what's going on
there as you're seeing a guy who's been
you know sort of beaten down that day or
whatever and your dad stops being
Superman and he's just this guy yelling
at the TA and I could get me son and
like you can yeah like this this like
he's white-knuckle and he's hanging on
which flies like this oh this guy isn't
you know bulletproof right it just gives
you this unsettling feeling maybe things
aren't gonna be okay right you get all
of that out of that that thing I don't
think my dad ever let his guard down I
can only remember like one time you know
I'd be up late at night or something and
I'd see his his lamp would be on and I
found out he hadn't been sleeping well
or something and I go like dad were you
up late last night and he's like oh yeah
just some trouble sleeping and like
clearly he was going through something
or add something that was keeping him up
yep to this day never knew he never
never let his guard down so in the show
what you would do is you would show what
was going on he said that line would be
hilarious right there gonna be so big
and so [ __ ] ridiculous and it'd be
like just totally be like the biggest
understand
yeah this is not making me want to get
back into the writers room yeah just
because those are the things that I
[ __ ] love yeah
about uh do just send all the dumped
like the [ __ ] that they let you do I
remember like when we used to drive to
school the giant yellow bus right the
guy driving the bus like he knows a big
thing can I open the door can I be the
door guy to be like yeah and you have
you standing like it's on the windshield
as you drove down the street no see and
you got to open the doors you felt all
special and [ __ ] like that and right if
you waving it constant freckled-faced
kid like you know you might as well hit
me on the hood oh that's great I feel I
I think and I don't know maybe it's just
the people that I've interacted with it
seems like parents are way more
humanized now like the the parents are
way more allow themselves to show their
vulnerability that's also because
everybody's filmed it out so you have
all these kids filming the parents
screaming at them and putting them
online see I guess but I more mean like
the people that I interact with or
growing up and stuff it just seemed like
the younger the kids got the more they
had this sort of relationship of equals
with the - I didn't relate to at all my
big one that changed everything was that
show to catch a predator yeah that that
just I think made everybody from
nowadays feel like there's some pervert
behind every tree now it made me not
take lemonade including my my wife sent
me a video of my daughter and they were
at the park and she was showing like my
daughter would like walk like ten feet
away from her whenever fifteen feet and
then come running at her cuz that's a
new thing that she can run right and as
she was walking away like literally my
heart was in my throat that someone's
gonna come by just you know I swooped
her up or something like that like so I
I don't know if it's cuz of watching
those I don't know how my mother would
just go outside and play get out yeah
you don't send us outside all day and
then literally ring a dinner bell like
four cattle come running in the other
triangle she just had like this little
like little [ __ ] Bell or something
like that so I don't know that's the
stuff that I think you know where she
got his bikes and we just drove away
just left drove miles away yeah I carry
streets and
this [ __ ] and didn't have a phone didn't
have anything like right now like it's
even worse right it was the same here
yeah you'll just be back when it's time
to come back give it back literally when
the street lights were on because in the
first season we did that and there on
you run you run home I brought my son to
like the mall and we're just walking
around the mall whatever but I'm holding
his hand and I had no idea what happened
but the minute that I just kind of let
go of his hand because he wanted to run
I let him run but the minute there was
like any sort of separation now I'm like
in this like this panic comes in over my
whole body with a second kid or third
kid because they said the first kid gets
their worst like my sister and me I was
treated much more strict and then she
could kind of do a sure you were treated
strict yeah things that you very you did
yeah yeah they held on too tight right
yeah I guess I was a 38 special alert
put some in his mouth well now like
didn't somebody parents got up like in
trouble or whatever for like letting
their kids walk to school right yeah
it's a good thing that story that
happened somewhere around here oh really
yeah like they were like the school was
like you know a half a mile away
whatever and then the kids are just
walking to school and their parents got
like called up on like family services
for like letting the kids walk to school
wow yeah that's different world I don't
know if that I don't I don't know
there's more perverts or it's just we're
so much more exposed to him now
hey dirty old men stay away from he's a
dirty old man okay but that was the
extent of you know the policing of it
yeah and then with like there was
something about that show and like how
just normal the people looked I mean
that [ __ ] show when they would catch
those guys to be like what he doing I
just came over here you know make sure
she was all right
oh my god all of those [ __ ] people
was just like like from the fondant and
vodka I wasn't I wasn't gonna use him I
wasn't no I know I wouldn't have done
that well well why did you bring the
condoms done no I don't know yeah no I
wasn't because she has just been a trap
door and those people went right down to
alligators so now would be a great way
to that first episode when I put it on
TV so they don't know what's happening
and you just watching
yeah yeah you gotta go sometimes you got
to go dictator that's it when the when
the 55 year old rabbi walks in and he
just looks like he's not like a like a
pervert or it just looks like a guy
who's a 55 year old rabbi and you just
starts reading the disgusting chat
transcripts and you're going it's
everywhere
it's just everywhere yeah that was the
others but I think yeah that wasn't that
was good and bad but like that's the
[ __ ] that now I know that I have a kid I
just sit there just instills paranoia
yes yeah I am
my wife's more chill around my kid and
I'm not I'm just all like everybody
coming to me like I just wish I had a
spear Bill's gonna be like a classroom
parent it was like okay see we'll see it
not at all say I'll sit thanks I'll sit
for the class myself this little desk we
love at involved parents but we just
think you know there is definitely a
line I'll sit back here you won't even
know I'm here don't worry about me
anyways so season 3 November 30th right
quick do you nervous like how is it
gonna be received or people don't like
it he just confident going in oh no
never never confident never come up it
so I'm season three I feel like this is
our best season or whatever but there is
kind of that you know after three days
staring at the phone like is the fun
over it's just our little thing you know
for like the last year and a half like
all of us working on the show what like
no one has seen it really outside of the
people at the network and that's what
the thing is tonight if the Paley Center
is we are showing the first episode of
the new season that's like we're
premiering that we're going to screen it
at the thing tonight comedy festival
thing so tickets still available I think
but uh so we're gonna show for an
audience which is always great because
we never get to watch it with in like
with people and audiences we just watch
it ourselves so it'll be fun to see
people think of it and why Comedy
Festival dot-com if you want to get
tickets and you guys will all be there
obviously yeah yes and so we're still in
the holding pattern of if this is a
success maybe we'll do season four yeah
we feel pretty good we've Netflix has
been hugely supportive and then every
time we they come
to the read-throughs of the new scripts
and they they watch the cuts they give
us very small notes and that they're
really behind it so you know we have a
pre but it's a very optimistic cuz on
broadcast like you get the overnight
numbers and everyone gets them yeah
we're like a box office you sort out
what it did so it's a different metric
system where they don't reveal what the
numbers are anyone's trying to crack the
code but you can get a sense of what the
fan response is and you look online and
Twitter and people engage with the show
which is nice but you never really so
Netflix just eventually tells you either
good or bad
yeah they don't give you anything and
then it's like the public reads about it
you know you your favorite shows like
these Marvel shows they're canceling and
stuff recently yeah just don't have any
idea until they're like it's done he's
not a great negotiator to put itself
into and we know the numbers and you
don't so yeah we don't find out how many
people are listening to us even more or
less until contract negotiation time and
you can kind of read at that point I was
picture that John Candy when he's
playing in stripes when he's playing
poker with that guy and he was just
looking at his cards and everything else
you know you don't want to do this it's
like they're kind of holding the cards
but then also a toast the the great
thing about like those kinds of networks
those is that's how you're able to like
become an international act though is oh
yeah because it's everywhere yeah so I
feel like you know it was like back in
the day when you know I used to do you
know Opie Anthony and Jim show like the
we come in and Sirius wasn't paying us
but like they used to literally cut a
commercial they used to let us cut
commercials for our gigs right and like
that's how I became a draw like I became
a draw in all those Opie and Anthony
markets and all of that [ __ ] and so
there's always like that that you know
there's always if you have an act you
can go do you can always make up
definitely whatever is going on
definitely